as a cultural commentator here at the
daily wire i i am
very soon going to have to sit through
a geography of dr fauci this coming out
from disney plus
the the dr fouchy documentary of this
living
saint
who who seems to glide across the earth
with the lightest and most angelic touch
of any bureaucrat in the government
when i think about my dad growing up i
certainly think about that seriousness
but very few people get to see
he's funny weird and really playful god
help us
in 1981 hiv aids was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
government's response when you got sick
you were gone fast it's affecting you
now yeah
why
post-traumatic stress syndrome
when coveted hit he became this target
my dad said we're gonna get through this
whole thing and he's held that you don't
do it because you want to make money you
don't do it for the glory you do it
because you care when you're involved in
a race to stop a horrible disease
you always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
it's not that dr fauci
has not been doing things quickly enough
it's that he's been doing the wrong
things
that's the problem he does things pretty
quickly he takes power very quickly he's
been doing it since the 80s but he he
just does the wrong things they're
trying to make him out to be the hero of
aids dr fauci completely botched aids
i we we've we've got to put out maybe
we'll put out some
series or something on that we've got to
we've got to put out some information he
blew dr fauci is i'm not going to say
he's the villain of aids but he is
he is one of the people who really
really blew it and he blew it in a
similar way to the way that he blew
kovid 19.
okay post-traumatic yeah you probably do
have post-traumatic stress syndrome
because
you blew it buddy
and and yet because he he might not be
the most scientifically or medically
adept but he is extremely politically
adept which is how he's stuck around
so long i'm so glad you liked that clip
if you want the whole episode you can
subscribe here you know ring the bell
hit the smash do the whatever i don't
know on youtube you can do that that's
fine but if you want the full show
without any of the big tech censorship i
would go check it out at apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your podcasts you can subscribe
for free to the michael knowles show
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]